so hey before we get to the proper
podcast I wanted to do a quick prologue
to let you know that the 10th annual
project for awesome is this week the
indiegogo fundraiser starts on Wednesday
for those who don't know the project for
awesome is nerdfighteria annual 48 hour
charity event there will be a live
stream all day Friday and Saturday until
Sunday at noon you can find that at
youtube.com slash vlogbrothers during
the second half of the fundraiser we'll
be raising money for charities chosen by
the nerdfighter community you can
participate in the voting and everything
else at projectforawesome.com where you
can also find the fundraiser if you
donate you can get lots of great perks
including an exclusive episode of dear
Hank and John so please donate if you
can but regardless I hope to see you in
the project for awesome livestream and
over at projectforawesome.com thanks for
listening now here's me and Hannah hello
and welcome to dear Hank and John it's a
comedy podcast about death where myself
John Green and my brother Hank green
although not this week because he's on
eternity leave answer your questions
provide you with dubious advice and give
you all the week's news from both Mars
and AFC Wimbledon today I am joined by
the amazing the brilliant Hannah Hart
how are you I'm doing pretty well John I
have to say it's an honor thank you so
much for having me well thank you I
appreciate you filling in for Hank you
have been one of my favorite youtubers
since your very first upload I am not to
brag an old-school hipster Hannah Hart
fan I knew about you when you had like
500 subscribers yeah and that makes me
super cool and hip and with-it
but for those people who may not be will
you talk a little bit about your work
and perhaps do some self promo oh yeah I
would I would love nothing more if Tyler
Oakley has taught us anything it's how
to do self-promotion it's so true so
true well first of all thank you so much
John for believing in me from the get-go
for those of you who don't know my name
is Hannah Hart I uploaded back in March
of 2011 a video called my drunk kitchen
which originally was just a folk joke
intended for a friend but was public and
then lots of people John included
from there I learned all about the
internet community of a wonderful little
convention called VidCon it was a second
annual VidCon that was really great
that's where I learned how to internet
and now five years later I have a
channel that does more than just my
drunk kitchen though my drunk kitchen is
still a weekly occurrence
I have weekly to the best of my ability
at youtube.com slash heart dough I've
also done a couple movies and written a
couple books most recently buffering
unshare tales of a life fully loaded
which is my book all about well you know
it's a comedy book all about death
mental health and itself self-help for
those of you who haven't read buffering
it is a really wonderful memoir it is
gut-wrenching and oh my god it's just a
great story brilliantly told so it's one
of my favorite books of the year and and
I think everybody should pick it up I'm
gonna be talking about it in my holiday
book roundup so Hanna generally we start
off this podcast with me reading a short
poem and I haven't been doing that the
last few weeks and the listeners have
been furious I don't like to like give
in to popular opinion but in this
particular case I'm going to because the
volume of email that we've gotten in
read my refusal to read short poems has
been totally unacceptable so here is a
couplet from samuel taylor coleridge not
my favorite poet but i do rather like
this couplet to meet to know to love and
then to part is the sad tale of many a
human heart that john well you got to do
there like the finger-snapping yeah oh
yeah I mean I'm a huge huge fan of
poetry I don't know if I told you this
but recently I actually got I got a Mary
Oliver line tattooed to my body did you
really I did yeah there's a there's a
well no big mary oliver fan what what
line did you get tattooed on your body
from Blackwater woods I got to love what
is mortal tattooed and I Maddie for
those hmm it's it's like I got a done
when buffering became a best-seller and
it was just like a really great day to
file
they get that story out there and share
it and for those of you who aren't
familiar with that poem it's a great
poem it's a it so it's longer than the
last stanza but the last stanza says to
live in this world you must do three
things to love what is mortal to hold it
against your bare bones as if your life
depends on it and when the time comes to
let it go to let it go
and so mmm a big fan of impermanence and
the constant reminder of it so I put two
love what is mortal on my ribs to tell
myself you know what Hannah go ahead get
attached love this life it's a great one
oh man you're gonna make me cry even
before we start providing dubious advice
to our listeners because I miss hanging
out with you in real life it's one of
the very few things that makes me want
to move to Los Angeles is the thought of
being able to hang out with you more oh
thank you I feel the same way all right
we're gonna answer a question this one
comes from Katie I'm just gonna read it
to you at Hannah and this I'm just gonna
prepare you it's a tough one
she writes dear John and Hank I am a
college student and I currently live in
a house with three other girls here's my
problem two of my housemates are
identical twins and I have no idea which
one is which they look the same sound
the same they have the same glasses they
are together most of the time and I
haven't yet encountered a situation
where I needed to know who was who but I
feel like a terrible person for not
knowing I feel like the time to ask this
question would have been when I met them
in August and now it's November and the
ship has sailed
I mean I don't think it's first of all I
think that if you can't tell them apart
they probably already know right yeah
like totally yeah they're probably a
hundred percent no and they probably
have got that their whole lives Oh Katie
that's like a deli
that's a dilly of a pickle but I feel
like you probably just got a pony up and
just Nick hey guys is there an easy way
to tell you two apart right like I mean
isn't it kind of the twins fault for
wearing the same style of glasses I mean
that's that's just not nice that's not
being nice to that to the wider world I
feel like there's you can have slightly
different glasses you just got it you
just gotta ask you just got to be like
which of you is Melissa and which of you
is Janet
in defense of the twins and all twins
everywhere it must be really hard when
one of them gets like a really cool
hairstyle the other one it's kind of
like doing a test run for a look right
now if they die they're very certain
color you're like oh man that looks
great I gotta get on right I guess
that's true I don't know I feel like I
well I've never been a twin so I don't
want to try to put myself in that
position or to speak on behalf of twins
but I think in this situation the key is
just to go and be as honest as you can
and be like look you guys have the same
glasses I've only known you for four
months by the way like I often don't
know people's names the four months just
in general yeah people even I'm really
close to like I know like you hang out a
lot with like mamrie Hart and then
there's another one who's very nice and
she's friendly and she was in a Lowe's
commercial and she's a lovely person but
I have no idea what her name is
oh man and you've gotten by four years
off of that like nope nobody's called
you out on it no we've been in videos
together and the whole time I'm just
like it's so nice to see you you're so
great I love your work which is true I
just don't know her name
I feel like I feel like we did yeah we
did a really good job answering that
like we do salt we killed it I mean
we're already off to a great start let's
answer another question this one comes
from Victor who writes Dear John and
Hank is it okay to laugh at a joke made
by a total stranger that I happened to
overhear or am I supposed to pretend I
didn't hear it what if it's a great joke
I mean I would say laugh odds are they
probably wouldn't even know this right
like you could be laughing at something
you saw on your phone but don't you
think a lot of the times that people
make jokes in public spaces out loud
like if I'm in a movie theater before
the movie starts and somebody makes a
joke and it's really funny I usually
laugh because I assume that they're
making it partly for me you know like
usually when I when I'm making a joke in
a public space I'm kind of hoping that
everyone laughs at it and that like
people turn around and they're like well
aren't you a genius well I think
that is a very unique and special trait
but in one that is probably pretty
common amongst those of us who like to
really just share our thoughts and
opinions constantly you know sometimes I
just get Labrador if I think I'm really
driving home a great point and everybody
should hear ya
holy pause applause really I just wait
for the Sara often comments that when we
are out buying clothes or something I'm
constantly like telling jokes and trying
to make her laugh but I'm really trying
to make the salesperson laugh because
I'm uncomfortable and I'm trying to make
everyone else comfortable and it's very
much like that where I will not stop
until there is a standing ovation
nothing like nothing like forced
laughter to really just take the
awkwardness out of a situation
good plan that's good oh god no I'm the
worst I'm so bad at shopping for clothes
every part of the shopping experience I
make miserable
I always just get into conversations
this is what happens to me and when I go
shopping or am taking a lyft or an uber
or something like that I always end up
hearing the life story of everyone I
encounter like it's been pointed out to
me recently that I can't have an
interaction with a person at a
restaurant or a coffee shop without
walking away from it with personal
details about their life or their day I
don't know how this happens but it's
true but you do have kind of a gift for
making people open up I feel that way
about you actually like I've probably
cried more in front of you than in front
of most of the people I know although to
be fair I am something of a crier I
watched a soldiers coming home video
today soldier comes home to surprise
mother on Thanksgiving and icon it's a
rough one oh man I just was like they're
so happy I yeah I mean I there are times
when I need to cry like when I watch a
series of YouTube videos for the purpose
of crying but it is not it is not
difficult to to coax the tears out of me
I would say that I used to be on this
drug that prevented me from crying and
it was a real bummer I rely genuinely
disliked it like it was part of
treatment for my OCD and now I'm on a
drug that doesn't prevent me from crying
and it
a huge improvement in the quality of my
life I think because there are times
when I really like I need to cry and I
want to be able to cry I want to be able
to feel the whole range of human emotion
and ha I mean these days I honestly just
obviously I don't want to cry when I'm
just like overwhelmed with you know
sadness but there are times when it can
feel really cathartic yeah absolutely I
mean and all physically it is because I
think that you release certain hormones
through your tears I mean it's like
there are physically there's there's
benefits to crying so Viktor made it
instead of laughing at someone's joke
just sob how did we get to this part of
the answer I don't
we're so bad I'm so bad at podcasting
here I don't want to throw you under the
bus you're great but I'm terrible okay
do you want to ask a question yeah all
right go for it Oh actually I kind of
when I asked this one let me know if
this is true I'm just curious
Niki writes an ass dear Hank and John
this time Hannah and John where's the
line between the Far East and Middle
East who decided where that line is and
why does no one ever say the Near East
well Nikki these are all made-up ideas
there's no line well one of the weird
things about the way that we imagine the
world right is even continents are kind
of made up like afro-eurasia is really
kind of a continent definitely Eurasia
is a continent but we still make this
distinction between Asia and Europe and
then what I think of as East Asia
doesn't have much in common
geographically with for instance Saudi
Arabia it all just points to the fact
that at its core all of these ideas
around geography go back to old colonial
days like even the idea of the West and
the East like west of what east of what
you know so I think it's good to be
calling into question what these things
mean and to think about these terms and
their implications because a lot of
times they're basically used as ways to
describe what is other or what is
distant from quote-unquote us right
exactly it's kind of like remnants
remnants of a past self-absorption yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean I I hope a past
self-absorption but I worry a little bit
well I worry a lot that that
self-absorption isn't totally past like
there's still a lot of Eurocentrism yeah
meg asks dear Hank and John I'm
currently dating a really wonderful girl
and have been for a while we're both
seniors in different high schools but
only live about 20 minutes away from
each other she's planning on moving to a
different continent after graduation
next fall and I'm planning on going to
university somewhere in Canada she said
she doesn't think she can do
long-distance but also doesn't want to
break up right now how do I deal with
being in a relationship that feels like
it has an expiry date hmm that's a great
question but I just want to pause real
quick to note that continents are at
least to an extent a made-up idea I also
like say love knows no bounds so that's
a bit of good news for you Meg on the
yeah I actually have experience in a
relationship like this have you ever
been in a relationship like this Hannah
my first girlfriend was exactly this
relationship yeah I so what happened
walk me through it and then I'll tell
you how how it went down for me oh man
so we started dating as my first
girlfriend ever I was you know totally
in the closet it was my sophomore year
of college and we started dating around
January or February something like that
and I was already scheduled to go to
Japan for my semester abroad in August
so we blissfully were dating but little
did I know that she thought of me
leaving for Japan as kind of when we
would just stop whereas I thought we
were in a relationship and so every time
we talked about keeping in touch long
distance the these terms were really not
well defined and so I actually just
ended up having like my beating heart
ripped from my chest it was horrible
because I didn't view it as something
with an expiry date I just was like
right yeah
bad man I mean I know what I would say
to this kid but I want to hear I want to
hear what your experience with this was
like so when I was in my mid-20s I've
been dating a woman for a couple years
and she decided that she was gonna move
to Italy where she was originally for
him so she was gonna move back to Italy
and it was immediately clear that like
since it was a semi-permanent move that
that was going to be when we were gonna
break up and it was definitely weird I
mean we we communicated well about it
and we knew we had similar expectations
going into it but it got weird as we got
closer to the date for sure because we
were just like so I guess we're still
doing this but at the same time we're
aware that we're not going to be doing
it forever on the other hand I mean I'll
just wreak wote to you that mary oliver
line tool of what is mortally you know
you have to let it go let it go and it
was difficult but I also really valued
those last few months of the
relationship not least because as it
happens she introduced me to Sarah
oh yeah right at the end of our
relationship so so Sarah was a boxer and
so was this young woman and they were
sparring partner physical yeah like an
actual boxer like Golden Gloves dog how
did Sarah get cooler and cooler
I know I know I'm super lucky so yeah so
she was a boxer and they were sparring
partners and one day my girlfriend at
the time was talking about how she'd
just gone to this wedding in Alabama and
Sarah was like I'm from Alabama where's
your boyfriend from and it came out that
Sarah and I had actually gone to the
same high school and so we met up I mean
we didn't start dating for like a year
after after this this Italian a breakup
thing but but yeah yeah so sometimes you
never know meg you never know life is
weird but but you do know I will say
this you know a you're in high school so
no I'm gonna go ahead and say the
majority of high school relationships
don't last spoiler
well no relationships last they all end
in death if they don't end before death
very true guys nope they always really
help
that's true you know born alone die
alone let's not forget for even a second
actually but I guess what I'm going to
say is that as you grow and mature in
your relationships make you should
notice that the majority of this
paragraph is written about what she
wants and what her plans are you should
figure out what it is that you want and
whether or not you can handle the
emotional weight of falling deeper and
deeper in love with someone who's going
to be leaving so you have to ask
yourself what do you want do you want to
bear the emotional weight of being in
love with someone that's going to end up
leaving or not but you know at the end
of the day it might also be a good test
run you never know work out those like
communication kinks you're gonna have to
work out in every relationship yeah also
it's a-you know life is very long and
who knows you go to university on
different continents insofar as
continents are a thing and then you're
25 or you're 30 or you're 70 and you
meet in the old folks home and you fall
back and love life is weird and I I do
think that there's obviously there's an
element of you have to plan for your
future you have to make commitments to
people you have to honor those
commitments but there's also an element
in it of you know now being really the
only guaranteed time you have so it's
really I think ultimately the question
comes down to balancing that and as you
pointed out understanding your needs and
your wants and what's important to you
as well as what's important to the
person you love yeah really meditative
you guys since you already know that
there might not be a future you have no
choice but to really just stay in the
present Hannah
we have another question and this one
comes from Hannah I don't know if it's
you but it's someone named Tana Dear
John and Hank I am a fan of many
different online creators I love their
work and would like to support it the
problem is that I am a broke college
student this person doesn't sound like
necessarily you but who knows for sure
I'm a very broke college student I feel
guilty about consuming content from
these creators and not being able to
support them but spending money on
supporting these creators would mean
less money for me to feed myself and
other things important to my life how
can I deal with this guilt until I reach
a point in my life where I am
financially capable of supporting their
work while still being able to support
myself Wow
oh my god first and foremost as an
online creator I'm pretty sure and you
know correct me if I'm wrong John but
I'm pretty sure we create and share
because that's what we'd love to do yeah
I love I love to make things and put
them out there on the Internet and while
the financial support that comes from
selling merchandise etc is great if it's
available to those who have the means
there is absolutely no obligation on
your behalf to do it if it's going to
mean you know withdrawing from the only
money you have to feed yourself I would
strongly prefer you feed yourself
totally I mean one of the reasons that
we make stuff in a way that can be
freely distributed is so that it's
available to people who can't afford to
pay for it right like that's one of the
great benefits of YouTube it's one of
the reasons that Hank and I have worked
really hard over the years to make sure
that as much stuff as possible that we
make is available for free for everyone
because we understand that the vast
majority of people can't afford to pay
for it and you know we want you to take
care of yourself way way way before you
ever take care of us the only thing I
would add to that Hannah yeah I don't
know if you agree with this
but I just want to encourage this Hannah
who is not you I want to encourage this
Hannah to remember us when she becomes a
wildly successful billionaire yeah it's
true please do remember us the people
that provided you with entertainment but
you know what John what I also have
something I would like to say to this
Hannah who is not me okay
you are not responsible for the needs of
others and by putting yourself into
their heads and causing your own guilt
that's not great dude I do this a lot
because I'm a huge care taker I feel
guilty I would say that guilt is like by
default emotion and because we are
giving freely you are free to accept so
try and remember that but that we are
giving the amount each person is giving
the amount that they are choosing to
give right and you can't presume
that they need more from you until they
say it yeah I mean frankly I'm so
grateful to anybody who takes my work
into their lives and finds a use for it
finds um you know meaning in it that's
it that's that's the exchange for me and
if somebody can afford to buy a t-shirt
that's great but if they can't that does
not make them in any way less of a fan
to my mind yeah absolutely
absolutely John I have a question
actually for you from Cherie okay that I
have been thinking about here's my
question to John from Hanna I say Dear
John and Hank who's not here what's it
like when people tattoo things to their
body forever that is because of you or
your work like quotes that you've said
or like ideas that you've had like to
know that that it's meant so much to
someone like that they put it on their
bodies forever well not forever because
they're gonna die but yes I understand
the question the entirety that their
body right so I used to have this joke
that I used for a long time because this
started happening weirdly early because
even you know like Looking for Alaska my
first novel was not very commercially
successful but for whatever reason a lot
of the people who read it early on like
really took to it and really responded
to it very deeply which was tremendously
meaningful to me and fulfilling for for
me and I remember the first time you
know somebody emailed me a picture of
something that I'd written on their
bodies it was on their forearm and I was
just like oh my god so I used to have
this joke where I would say I think it's
great as long as it's your second tattoo
because I don't want to be responsible
for somebody's first tattoo but then I
got this very wonderful and moving email
from someone who was like I tattooed
something that you said onto my body as
my first tattoo because it meant that
much to me and I don't love your joke
about it being okay as long as it's my
second tattoo because it makes me feel
like you're dismissing oh yeah
yeah John that's you downplaying your
myself myself and my passion so uh I now
am just grateful period end of sentence
I think it's amazing I don't think
anybody should feel obligated to tattoo
anything that I've said onto their
bodies but I think it's amazing and I
you know it's just so so many years ago
I did a book signing with Stephenie
Meyer the author of Twilight and I had
like maybe three to four fans in the
audience and Stephenie had between like
five and six million and a lot of the
people who were at that event were
wearing homemade t-shirts about Twilight
and I just remember thinking that is the
coolest thing I have ever seen and it
sucks that I will never be that kind of
author that people respond to like so
deeply I'm so passionate in spire them
to to create something on their own yeah
right and then the first time I saw
somebody wearing a t-shirt inspired by
one of my books that they'd made
themselves I just remember thinking like
oh my god
oh my god it's happening and it's just
that was that's one of the best feelings
I've ever had in my that's true and we
you know people even with even if it
doesn't show up in the form of tattoos
like we as humans impact each other
every time we interact you know yeah so
yeah I was just curious about that I
also kind of want to ask this Nightmare
Before Christmas one sure ask it Alyssa
writes dear Hank and John is The
Nightmare Before Christmas a Halloween
movie or a Christmas movie ask me for a
friend it's a tough one I've been
thinking about it since I chose it well
what is it I'm gonna go ahead and say
it's a Halloween movie yeah I mean it
kind of is right like it's all about
like for its its you know first of all
the songs like here comes Halloween here
comes Halloween like that's like the
like big song from it second of all it
ends with the jack like accepting well
maybe it's a journey of self acceptance
but
ends with him like praising Halloween
and the purpose of that holiday you know
and even though it takes place like over
Christmas time I would say that it's
it's a Halloween movie to show that
Halloween's got its benefits well here's
the reason why I'm gonna say it's a
Halloween movie and I I think you're
right and I think that is a far better
point than the one that I'm about to
make but I'm gonna say it's a Halloween
movie because it was released to
theaters on October 29th 1993 you know I
can't type right now because I'm so
worried about ruining my vo I type yeah
I'm typing the whole time you don't
think I had to look up that mary oliver
quote you think I got that stuff
memorized not written on my ribs oh my
god well you know there's a there's
actually a second part to the man I
don't want to derail the podcast too
much into John and Hannah catch up but
I'm gonna get after to love what is
mortal I'm like combining my other
favorite Mary Oliver poem or one of my
many favorites which is someone I once
loved gave me a box full of darkness it
took me years to realize that this too
was a gift mm-hmm and so I have always
spent my whole life like learning to
love my box full of darkness and
realizing that it was a gift so I'm
gonna get to love but what it's been
hard for me is B is happiness and
attachment and relief and and accepting
that you love things even though you
know you will lose them eventually
so I'm great so I have to love what is
mortal
with a and then after it I'm going to
write I'm going to add this to is a gift
hmm that's great that's great I mean I
never have tattoos ideas of that quality
like the only tattoo ideas I have are
like I should get the AFC Wimbledon
crest tattooed on my back and like
that's not a good idea
deep down can I read you my favorite
Mary Oliver poem since we're in Mary
Oliver fangirl mode Wow alright it's
from I think the books called a thousand
mornings I go down to the shore in the
morning and depending on the hour the
waves are rolling in or moving out and I
say oh I am miserable
what shall
what should I do and the C says in it's
lovely voice excuse me
I have work to do yeah she's so good
she's so good she's so good she's so
good it's just like
I live in a city I live in Los Angeles I
don't have as much exposure to nature as
I like but I really love her way of of
writing and connecting with nature that
it's not personifying it fully but in
the way that she personifies it she adds
the depth of human feeling to it you
know it's like even with the words with
this moment what shall I
you know what shall what should I do the
waves are just breathing it's like the
Earth's form of like a breath in right
without you know right yeah and you can
feel that in the rhythm or the meter or
whatever of her poetry as well like in
the rhythm of the lines it's she's just
an astonishingly good poet everybody
should just read Mary Oliver books and
Hannah Hart's book buffering we should
start a podcast called poetry porn
Hannah jawed talk about poems the
podcast and it should really just be
marielle like we should just started
Mary Oliver fan podcast because I bet
there isn't you know there are so many
podcasts out there but is there a Mary
Oliver fan podcast
hold on I'll google it right now I'm so
ready I am so ready for there is not
there is not there is not a podcast
devoted entirely to Mary Oliver's work
there of course podcast episodes devoted
to them but I'm talking about a
full-time weekly update on what Mary
Oliver is up to this week
boom boom palme at a time book at a time
her journey and progressed look I'm such
a nerd don't get me started on this I'll
keep going like I'll just feel like this
is a great idea this is a great idea
should we answer more questions though
yeah let's ask a couple more questions
all right Hannah this question comes
from anonymous who writes Dear John and
Hank since I've turned 18 I've been
getting more politically engaged my dad
is very smart and he's helping me to
understand things but recently he and I
disagreed over something there have been
a few instances in the last couple years
of bakeries refusing to serve people of
different ethnicities or sexual
from their own well I think this is
disgusting I disagree with my dad's
opinion that it should be illegal and
that legislation should be put in place
to stop business owners from picking and
choosing who they sell to I know that
probably sounds horrible but on an
objective level I feel like it shouldn't
be the role of the government to tell a
private business owner who they should
or shouldn't serve is my dad right or am
i right
anonymous your dad is right you're I
think your dad is right because it
actually is the job of the government to
tell private business owners who they
should and should not serve because if
you don't do that you end up in a
situation where private business owners
don't serve people who are already
systemically disenfranchised so we saw
this in the South during Jim Crow the
problem wasn't just the legal public
segregation the segregation of private
businesses was also part of the reason
why african-american people didn't have
full equal rights under the law in the
United States and so legislation was
required in order to basically integrate
private enterprise which is important
because if we don't do that we end up in
a country where people don't
functionally have equal protection under
the law I mean I think yeah I completely
agree I think it goes to a question it
goes to a question of morality which is
something that I've been I've been
wondering about a lot lately because if
you believe it is wrong for someone to
refuse to serve a couple that is
homosexual or you know not not white
then how can you support someone's
freedom to do so that's a question I've
been wondering because you know in light
of the recent election I have been
baffled by how many people don't feel
responsible for their lack of action I'm
okay with people saying things that I
deeply disagree with or even things that
I find repulsive or hateful or offensive
and I don't think that that should be
illegal but that's very different from
whether or not businesses have to
provide services
to all people I just ultimately don't
buy the argument that it's okay
because I think we've seen in American
history over and over again that win
private enterprise is allowed to
discriminate they do in ways that
systemic lis disenfranchised people vote
I completely agree with you John
I think I mean it couldn't have said it
better myself all right let's answer one
more question before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon Hannah this is I don't know
how I don't know how excited you are to
find out the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon but it's been a big week for
both I'm pretty stoked I'm ready
just getting nothing ever happens on
Mars just happening very slowly you know
that's that's Hanks that's Hanks
position you're doing a good job being
Hank thank you thank you Victoria writes
dear Hank and John I just finished a
book that I needed to read for school a
few minutes ago and I started to wonder
when you finish a book should you just
slam it shut and move on to the next
book or do you sit and reflect over how
the book made you feel so I have a young
adult author friend who has a great
story about this I won't name the friend
but the first time she ever saw somebody
reading one of her books like in the
wild was in an airport and she sat down
like across the aisle from this person
who was finishing a book that this
author had written and she watched as
the person read the last five pages and
then like closed the book contentedly
and then kind of like stared into the
middle distance thinking about it and
she was just about to say like I wrote
that book when the reader stood up
walked to the trashcan and put the book
in the trash don't do that Victoria
don't do it just yeah just in case the
author is watching never throw a book
away in public I mean I just can't I
just don't even understand how people
about that is I can't think of anything
worse I thought this was going to be
like but like you know they closed the
book they stare off into the distance
and they shed a single tear and
when your friend knew like she would she
that writing was blah blah blah or
something beautiful about this yes no no
I went to the trash have you ever seen
somebody reading one of your books in
the wild I have not but I have seen
every time I go to an airport or a
bookstore I always get my book from
wherever it is you know rusting in the
back and I pick it up and I put it on
the recommended like top sellers like
front table and I think that that oh
yeah yeah I just put it up there on the
front
I saw someone pick it up flip through it
and put it down
that's the question everything I've seen
that a bunch of times with my books yeah
where I'm like and I want to be like
that's a good one you should get that
one but I never do I know I got my I
have to have my face on the cover of
mine so it's really hard for me to just
kind of like slide into that DM and be
like hey that's a great point book but
no to answer your question Victoria you
know for me when I finish the book when
I finish a book I do like to kind of
shut it and like look forward and just
kind of like bask in that feeling that
contentment of like wow wow that's good
yeah and it usually takes me I don't
know I probably usually takes me awhile
I can't just pick up the next book if it
was really a book that like I wanted to
digest or meditate on a little bit I
don't often just move to the the next
book I'm reading but if it's like a
beach read or it's like you know you're
at somebody's house and they've got
these really like you know there's some
kind of random book that's on that
impactful you could pretty much read one
of those and then just move on to the
next one but for me I like to I
definitely like to like marinate in it
yeah I don't think you have an
obligation to like have that period of
reflection after you finish a book but I
do think it's kind of nice like I like
that in fact like it's probably my
favorite part of reading a book is that
feeling of like reading the last 10
pages and usually I'm crying because I'm
just a crier even if it's like a comedy
book I've just enjoyed being in the
world so much I'm sad that I'm gonna
have to leave it and and then I liked
that feeling afterwards of just being in
though in the wake of it you know I
remember when I read the e Lockhart
novel we were Liars like after I read
that book it was I finished it like 1
o'clock in the morning and I was like
I'm not gonna go to sleep for a couple
hours because I'm gonna try to hold on
to this feeling for a little while and I
love that I love that emotion but I
don't think that it's an obligation and
I do sometimes I finish a book and I'm
just like yeah that was good Don and
done well I'll bomb yep done and done I
once linked the feeling of like
existential whoa like that profound
sadness - when you finish a series that
you've been enjoying for a really long
time and it's over and the story is
completely complete oh this is it this
is the diversity Eric Doe job do you
remember the Thorn Birds very vaguely
very vaguely so basically the Thorn
Birds is like this it's a story about a
family I don't know if it was a book or
a series or what but they made it into
like a miniseries and my best friend in
like middle school and I marathoned it
all one weekend and you watched the
entire story of this family's kind of
like these generations in this life from
childhood to death and as soon as it
ended I burst into tears and I was like
that's it and my friend was like what
are you what's wrong and I was like well
that's it that's it for them is over
yeah I'm just witnessed not just one
death but like the death of this entire
family right it is a weird it is a weird
thing to have to say goodbye to
characters that you've cared about
especially if you've cared about them
for more than one book it's there is
kind of a grieving process for me well I
do think it's a little bit I think it's
a little bit of an echo or a little bit
of a shadow of of death or of loss and I
think that's part of part of what I like
about reading is that it feels like a
somewhat safe place to to go there
emotionally yeah yeah some people say
our pets teach us how to love and lose
but for me it is multi-volume
young adult fantasy series on that note
we shall move on to the news from Mars
and AFC Wimbledon I'm gonna start with
the news from Mars which is that Elon
Musk who really wants to go to Mars
before 2028 Hannah I don't know if you
know this but Hank and I have a deal
that if humans do not get to Mars by
2028 I get to rename this podcast Dear
John and Hank so I am hard opposed to
human exploration of Mars before 2028 I
it's one of the very few things that I
feel extremely strongly about we need to
be an earth only planet for at least the
next 12 years anyway
Elon Musk who has big plans to go to
Mars but no chance of actually
accomplishing them he wants to get
humans to Mars around 2025 and he says
that it would cost humans the average
person just $200,000 for a round trip to
Mars I mean which is expensive compared
to like a trip to Paris but is very
inexpensive compared to I don't know
what it what you would think that it
would cost to go to Mars so if you have
200,000 dollars lying around and you
want to almost certainly die
check out that opportunity yeah Jesus
you know like this it's the I am so not
a fan of the idea of consume you know
it's funny actually Hank and I were
talking about this when we saw each
other in Missoula we were talking about
consumer based or like customer friendly
space travel and I'm a huge I'm a big
I'm a resounding no I'm like ah nope not
until it's like I mean I don't know if I
ever would do that you know do the
$200,000 trip to Mars no no I wouldn't
do it if you paid me $200,000 for stock
Wow no what a stupid idea it's exactly
like being in Marco Polo's time and
thinking I'm going to trek across
Eurasia
no no I'm not I'm going to stay in my
little French village and be a cobbler
yeah I'm gonna be a happy happy cobbler
I don't know though I often sometimes
think about the people that wanted to
like sale you know across the ocean and
stuff like that and I'm like maybe they
just had a TD you know because if I was
like sitting in my village and there was
a big mountain in the distance wouldn't
I be like you know we should probably
see what's on the other side of that
mountain you guys like what do you guys
think I thought I said that mountain
though I would like to think that's who
I am but in reality like I don't zip
line I'm not a brave person I like I'm
not a risk-taker
I love I think caution is the most
underappreciated virtue ah they're like
let us pause to give thanks for caution
which has protected so many of us from
so many terrible outcomes you know my
mother always taught me another word for
fear is intelligence that case I'm an
incredibly smart person alright moving
on to the news from AFC Wimbledon it's
been a fascinating and difficult week
for AFC Wimbledon everything is fine
nothing is so this is the third tier
English soccer team sponsored by
nerdfighteria Hanna they they wear
dftba on their shorts and they are
currently in seventh place which is just
outside the playoff spots but given the
fact that they were expected to be in
the very bottom of the table of the
third tier of English soccer this is
still things are still great however
they did tie their last two games a nil
nil draw against Millwall and then a 2-2
tie against Fleetwood which was
difficult because initially they were
one nail down but then eventually they
were to one-up and it looked like it was
going to be a one nail down to two one
up situation but then Fleetwood tied the
game in the last minute that's happened
to AFC Wimbledon like three or four
times the season where there's been a
last-minute goal against them that
robbed them of some points but vitally
by the time this podcast airs but not
yet in the time that it's being recorded
AFC Wimbledon will be playing a sixth
tier side in the FA Cup called kurzon
Ashton and should AFC Wimbledon win that
game they will then make it to the third
round of the FA Cup which is when all
the fancy famous teams like Manchester
United and Chelsea get involved and that
could be a huge opportunity so we're
gonna root for them to win that game so
that they can hopefully play like
Manchester United at Old Trafford and
get half the proceeds from selling
70,000 tickets or whatever Wow yeah
that's all you know you got to be like
financially savvy down there in the
third tier you really do also of of the
words you said and the half I understood
yeah good luck go to I hope you win your
game against Kersey lasting thank you
very excited very excited I mean I
should sponsor a rugby team I just wish
there was rugby in the states like like
professional rugby
why is there no rugby we've got some
pretty good we've got some pretty good
don't we have a really good national
women's team Celebi let me see yeah just
google it you could sponsor them by the
way I bet the u.s. women's national
rugby team is anxious for sponsorship
yeah well we may have just given Hannah
a new hobby and I can tell you from my
perspective sponsoring a somewhat
obscure sports team is probably the
single most fulfilling thing that's ever
happened to me I mean other than my
children and my lovely wife of course
it's just it's it's it's brought
incredible joy to my life yes the u.s.
women rugby Eagles there's you should
apps 100% the Eagles the Eagles are the
same as the men's team well so they both
the Eagles I don't know right now I am
looking at the shorts of the national
rugby teams and neither the men nor the
women have Hannah Hart's face on the
back of their shorts and that seems like
something that needs to be changed
immediately
missed this is a missed opportunity
although I have to say that watching the
Eagles the Eagles play the New Zealand
All Blacks were like the greatest team
in the world was pretty pretty brutal
but hey you know what these shirts look
pretty bare Hannah thank you for
podcasting with me it has been a great
joy absolutely thank you for having me
thanks to everybody for listening you
can emails questions that Hank and John
at gmail.com our podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins if you want to follow
me on Twitter you can do so at John
Green and Hannah you can follow me all
across the entire Internet at heart Oh
har T oh that's very good that's him
that's him solid self promo Tyler Oakley
himself couldn't have done it better
it really helps Twitter instead snapchat
YouTube they're all hard - it makes it
clean I I have taken a different social
media strategy which is having a
different name on each of those social
media platforms and also never using
them it's still a strategy rosianna
halse rojas hops up with questions
victoria Bongiorno runs our patreon and
social media accounts by the way
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
while we're plugging things our theme
music is by gunnarolla you should check
him out on YouTube he's brilliant
thank you again for listening and as we
say in my hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]
you